this is devonte chisholm reading for
reviewer jordan remedy a spin-off of
rainbow six siege ubisoft montreal's
team-based first-person shooter rainbow
six extraction doesn't initially present
as your typical rainbow six game but the
core gameplay tenets that define the
rainbow six games are present in
extraction yeah you're fighting aliens
but a successful mission is still
entirely dependent on teamwork
communication and your ability to adapt
to difficult situations it's a
compelling gameplay loop one made far
more fun if you have two friends to jump
into the fray with you
in extraction select members of
international counterterrorism unit
rainbow are called into form react a
team tasked with studying and fighting
against parasitic aliens called
archaeans as opposed to the player
versus player engagements of siege
extraction is entirely player versus
environment and extraction squads of
three are sent into incursions each
incursion a mission into an area
infested by the archaeans is divided
into three sub-zones with your objective
changing zone to zone as you progress
the difficulty of each zone increases
adding more enemy arcanes and better
rewards for completing objectives it's
up to you and your team to decide
whether to go for broke and complete all
three zones in a single incursion or
choose to extract from the mission early
if you complete an incursion you'll earn
huge amounts of experience potentially
increasing the strength of your
operators and unlocking new tech that
you can bring into follow-up incursions
but if your operator falls in battle
you'll not only lose experience but the
operator you are playing as will become
captured by the archaeans removing that
option to use that character to regain
the experience and the operator you lost
you'll need to replay the exact
incursion where you went missing in
action using a different operator and
successfully save your first character
from the archaeans it means that instead
of clearing all three zones extracting
early and keeping all the experience
you've currently accumulated even if
it's a smaller pot can be a smart choice
if the mission seems to be going south
compounding this choice is the fact that
operators retain health and tech zone to
zone if your teammate isn't watching
your back in the very first zone of an
incursion and you're suddenly ambushed
and taking a beating you may be walking
into zone 2 with only a small amount of
health instead of all of it with all of
your gadgets used up it's here that
extraction presents its most compelling
hook while also highlighting what is
potentially its greatest weakness your
squad's success is entirely dependent on
good communication and a fair bit of
democratic discussions around whether
the squad should push on or extract
early and this debate evolves over the
course of the mission many times i'd go
into an incursion filled with confidence
only for one mistake to convince me i'd
be better off trying to talk my allies
into bailing early a few minutes later a
chance discovery of a medical kit would
then give me enough hope that i'd be
able to last for at least one more zone
over mike's these communications are an
intriguing wrinkle encouraging you to
admit when you've possibly become a
liability to your squad or trust your
allies when they believe that one more
zone completion is possible it's a
wonderful sensation when your squad is
composed of folks willing to give
positive reinforcement relay information
to each other to reassure doubts and
collectively try to account for
potential weaknesses in the group it's
also a system that quickly falls apart
if you're not using mics and are instead
relying on the in-game ping system
extraction has a pretty good system that
can help with pointing out ammo crates
and coordinating attacks but it's a poor
substitute for the necessary nuance that
players need for deciding whether to go
forward or extract early if you're not
planning to jump on comms when you pick
up extraction you may find your fun
dulling a bit admittedly in many ways
this is similar to siege as well as
plenty of other team-based games but the
falloff in a team's performance when
players aren't speaking to one another
feels especially noticeable in
extraction given the random element of
what your squad is tasked with
accomplishing with each incursion
adaption is such a core part of
extraction which is just easier to pull
off if you and your allies share
information at the very least extraction
incentivizes teamwork via its challenge
and reward system you certainly can go
it alone but fighting without a full
squad is tough even my squads most
carefully laid plans quickly unraveled
the second any of us was laid out by
attacking enemies so whenever one of us
was close to running out of health and
going mia the general consensus was
typically let's get out of here plus
there's additional experience rewarded
for every operator successfully
extracted meaning you get more points
for bringing the whole team home than
finishing things solo when you're not
hashing things out with your teammates
you'll be shooting it out with the
arcades operators in their hardware
behave pretty much exactly as they do in
siege with a few alterations to certain
characters unique gadgets like iq and
jagr to make them more useful in pve
situations and honestly why mess with a
good thing
siege features tight gun play that
rewards a player patient enough to take
the right shot at the right moment
assault rifles feel a bit better than
other firearms in extraction given that
their long range is ideal for stealthily
taking out arcanes and their nest from a
distance and their high rate of fire is
well suited for taking on multiple
enemies at once at close range but the
overall pool of weapons is fairly
balanced even shotguns which are limited
to arcanes in your face range
comfortably fit into the meta while also
providing a means for breaching through
certain walls like siege extraction
features destructible environments where
select walls floors and ceilings can be
destroyed allowing operators to navigate
maps and surprise attack enemies from
multiple angles conversely you can
better defend your position from
approaching enemies by reinforcing
breakable walls or boarding up broken
windows and doors it's an interesting
consideration but not one that plays a
significant role in incursions reaching
your objective never requires careful
destruction of the environment and all
operators having access to silenced
weapons means you don't have to consider
alternative ways of circumnavigating an
archaean to avoid alerting a group
though breaking through walls is fun
it's never pushed forward by an
effective means of winning or more
easily traveling through certain
incursions that in turn lowers the
usefulness of operators with a unique
gadget aimed at breaching seeing as
opportunities to use their ability don't
pop up all that often in extraction
every operator utilizes a unique gadget
that allows them to aid the squad in
different ways though every operator is
useful in a different way a select few
are just more useful pulse's ability to
see through walls feels limited in
comparison to lion for instance seeing
as both operators can see enemies
through walls but lion can still shoot
while doing so right from the get-go
pulse eventually can after he levels up
a bit lion's ability may be limited in
that it needs to recharge between uses
and he can only see enemies while
they're moving but seeing as your squad
can just wait before pushing onwards to
the next fight and most type of
archaeans actively move about the map
it's not much of a trade-off the arcanes
and zone objectives play a hand in
uplifting certain operators as well
there are many types of archaeans each
possessing different traits the annoying
rooter can lock you into place for
example while the hissing bloater can
explode into a cloud of toxic gas
knowing which are up against and then
immobilizing them long enough to get to
their weak spot and stealthily taking
them out is paramount to success meaning
operators geared towards recon stealth
and stunning enemies excel similarly
though objectives are varied in their
design whether you're defending
locations in serial scan or sneakily
planting devices on our kian nest in
nest tracker they all boil down to find
a target and try to be quiet about it as
a result operators gear towards recon
and stealth stand out from the crowd
which isn't to say that operators that
naturally lean towards loudly locking
down an area like chichanka distracting
archaeans like alibi or breaching
through walls like habana are bad but
extraction's design encourages a
playstyle that supports operators who
tackle tasks via information gathering
like iq going unseen and unheard like
vigil and stunning enemies like ella
having previously worked together as
members of rainbow react's operators are
a wonderful variety of ages races and
nationalities many of them have
pre-existing relationships or a history
with the archaean parasites that dates
back to outbreak a limited time mode in
siege that has now become canon prequel
to extraction the game doesn't do
anything interesting with all this
narrative though ash thermite and mira
act as the voices in your ear while on
missions while detailing what's
happening in the world during stunningly
rendered cutscenes that unlock as you
progress through the game but it's all
just beautiful noise none of it is
compelling enough to dig through
extractions dozens of text files the
story is so immaterial it might as well
not even be there thankfully there's a
lot to unlock beyond more story as you
level up you'll earn additional
operators to play new maps with further
incursions to tackle more text to bring
into the field and skins to dress up
your favorite characters eventually
you'll unlock what constitutes
extractions and game content assignments
and maelstrom protocol assignments are
extremely difficult missions that change
week to week offering skilled players
more content to play through in order to
further level up their operators
maelstrom protocol is extraction's
ranked playlist where you go through
nine zone incursions instead of the
typical three earning points to raise in
rank and unlock seasonal rewards it's a
pretty healthy assortment of content to
play through at launch even if unlocking
it can be a grind once you hit the
latter half of the game's progression
track though you can earn experience
from completing incursions you net
yourself a lot more for completing
in-game challenges called studies these
studies are tied to certain maps so you
can't for example complete san francisco
studies while playing incursions in
alaska this system creates two problems
first off it can punish the player if
all your studies for alaska are to kill
two tormentors you're entirely dependent
on an incursion randomly spawning
tormentors so you could like me play
through several incursions on alaska and
make it all the way through all three
zones every time and not level up that
much because tormentors just never
spawned and studies don't expire until
they're completed so i had to keep
playing on alaska over and over until
tormentors finally spawned just so i
could complete those challenges and
unlock a new set to chase
and second studies net use so much
experience that it feels like the game
is encouraging the player to be a bit
selfish and forego the zone's objective
in order to do their own thing while
playing extraction i was constantly
reminded of halo infinite's challenge
system at the game's launch and that's
not a comparison you want your game to
make of course those are both issues
that are easily rectified by teammates
willing to talk to one another and work
together i had a wonderful time with
extraction working alongside my
teammates so that we could all complete
challenges at a steady pace without
completely ignoring the objective the
communication served us well when it
came time to decide whether to push
onward or extract reinforcing that
compelling team-based hook that made me
want to drop into incursions again and
again though the story is weak and the
design of the game favors certain
characters extraction is a good rainbow
six game that rewards you and your
team's ability to adapt and deliver a
compelling gameplay loop
i can't tell if you brought your a game
or this is too easy for you
you